foreign
[Music]
Navy SEAL you see before you is holding
a gun made by biofire
it's very very big claim is that it's
the first company to make a smart gun
that actually works
that's right
James Bond style fingerprint and facial
recognition
the gun only fires if the right person
is holding it it knows somebody's
holding on to it
but no matter how much he pulls the
trigger nothing's gonna happen
[Music]
the person who started biofire is Kai
klupfer
he's all of 25 years old and has been
working on making this gun for 10 years
a project he started shortly after the
Aurora theater shooting
at the time it's like the worst mass
shooting in history
and happened right just down the road
here from where I grew up
I was fortunate enough to not have to
think about gun violence or gun deaths
and that was really my first sort of
encounter with the topic right I was
just starting to grow up just starting
to think about these kind of topics as a
15 year old
and really start to think about how how
could we do something about this
I started thinking about this concept of
smart guy right by no means am I the
first person to think about this
obviously
and it's been in science fiction forever
but nobody had ever really built a
working smart guy
okay so you're 15 yep and instead of
doing some policy you're kind of you're
inspired yeah I was never a policy
person okay I've been forced to become a
little bit more of one you know over the
last 10 years but no I was an engineer I
I was a socially awkward nerd bona fide
nerd who clinched his nerd Bona fides by
getting an award at the very prestigious
Intel international science and
engineering fair so okay so for people
who don't know I mean this is like no
joke it's just like yes thousands of the
world's smartest yeah the year I went it
was the top 1500 out of over 8 million
people from here across the year right
yeah like this is like the top of the
top it's yeah it's as high as it gets
heading for the science fair world
at the time I was mostly an electrical
engineer
and I could sort of fake my way through
some mechanical engineering so built a
pretty good electrical system and a
really mechanical system
sort of slapped them together into this
kind of gun shaped object not an actual
firearm in any way I wasn't allowed to
bring a gun to the science fair quite
obviously
like I was very surprised by all this
you know I'd done a lot of science for
project before
three quarters of the time people didn't
believe that I had actually built them
they thought my parents had did them I
mean it's a nice way possible Dad I'm
sorry but
um my dad needs help like turning his
iPad on
after 10 years of toil Kai is
understandably proud that his business
finally has a product to sell to you
today we've got one of our uh Mark II
prototypes uh pre-production units of
the Mars smart gun
so as soon as I start to interact with
it I'm going to see those white lights
the white lights basically mean that
it's active it sees that somebody's
picked it up but it hasn't recognized
the user yet so it's still locked
to set up the gun you register your face
and fingerprints on this device in less
than a minute where you can also add and
delete other users
if you're not registered
nothing
fingerprints are very well optimized
very commercially mature you don't need
a lot of processing power to run them
appropriately facial recognition is a
Cutting Edge biometric which means it
requires orders of magnitude more
processing power so where previously we
were able to just use like little
microcontrollers and things like that to
do fingerprints we've had to basically
build an entire computer hardened for
the system you know that works inside of
a gun to be able to run facial
recognition at the speeds that our
customers demand
[Music]
if shotguns before but I'm far from a
gun enthusiast
in many ways on biofire's target
audience
a dad who wants to keep his family safe
but who also thinks having a gun at home
probably ends up more dangerous than
good
still old Gunner knew I needed a few
pointers yeah I would try to lean
forward like just like Lean Like lean
into it a little bit oh yeah there you
go
okay and again the target's like less
than 10 feet away so you don't need to
worry too much about anything I'll point
that out sorry the target is like 100
plus years away and Ashley is about to
you know do a marksman level his short
shot here
am I cool to try it yep
there you go
it still had more kick than I thought it
was going to it's all good
it kicks and from my experience it works
the question is will it sell
several companies have tried and failed
to make a smart gun because it's really
hard to do and not just because you're
mixing sensitive Electronics with
regular explosions okay so you've chosen
to do a startup doing this incredibly
hard technology and then to weigh it
into like a second amendment sort of
issue right so this is like nightmare
yeah that keeps it interesting that as
Kai has a talent for doing is putting
the controversy mildly pro-gun folks
hate these things because they fear that
one day the government will use the
existence of a working smart gun to ban
the dumb ones even flirting with smart
guns leads to death threats and
financial risks one of the reasons
biofire's investors prefer to stay
Anonymous and plenty of anti-gun folks
don't like them because you know they're
guns for his part Kai's not interested
in mandating or even advertising his
product biofire he says is just here to
provide choices and maybe save lives
the key thing that we are trying to
solve which I think we could completely
solve is children and teenagers getting
access to firearms
Firearms are now the leading cause of
death for children teenagers in America
they surpass motor vehicle accidents for
the first time in 2020. I've never
talked to a gun owner who wanted their
kid to find their gun and so we think
that by Building Technology that you
know busy works with the gun owner to
enforce what they're already looking to
do allows us to really actually address
that portion of the of the challenge of
busy gun deaths in America
the final version of biofire's gun
arrived in April with this funky sci-fi
look it's definitely more Halo than Red
Dead Redemption
but how well it will sell is anyone's
guess we want to look modern and
futuristic and a little different than
everything else that's on the market
obviously
when I saw that one it does have a
little sci-fi thing going on again we
don't want it to look too normal but we
don't want it to look like only you know
something that the Sci-Fi nerd would
like myself a cyber trucker so yeah
[Music]